uh okay let's go to the phones at
617-830-4750 see what's on people's
minds
let's go first to our caller from the
917
area code who we last spoke to in uh
oh it's been a year actually 917. what's
going on
hi david hi um i'm calling about
um the genocide that's going on in
xinjiang china
against the turkic peoples including the
uyghurs yes um
there's a there's a bill that's been
like in committee since
march um called i think the uyghur
forced labor prevention act
um which i believe which would
which would cause corporations that have
factories in xinjiang
to prove that their supply chains don't
include uh slave labor from uyghurs
rather than
in other words they would it put the
burden on them and i just sort of wanted
to make kind of a shout out for that
legislation there's been very little
pressure that i've seen put on people to
to make progress on that
um and i just think that's really
crucial um
because right now sort of like we are
all probably walking around
uh in clothing in face masks i mean all
kinds of things that are made
by these you know a million people
detained
um and that's sort of like a very
pressing human rights issue
yeah i think that one of the things that
is an interesting aspect of this that
maybe isn't being discussed is
when we talk about american relations
with china
one of the realities we have to face is
that
the worse our relationship is with china
the less leverage we have to get them
to change their behavior or to make
demands or whatever and so
you know a lot of the discussion about
trump and china is about were the
tariffs a good or bad idea or
is the relationship between china and
russia that builds
when the us is increasingly on the outs
in that group of three countries
beneficial or not
but there's this other reality that if
trump cared to do something about what's
going on there
we have a lot less leverage when our
relationship is bad
and and when we cut ties and that's sort
of like an
ancillary intangible that we have to
understand is affected by the
relationship the oval office has with
china
can i sort of put another way put
another way of looking at that yes it's
not an argument this is sort of a
reframing is like
one of the things i think about is when
we look back
you know 10 years from now we're saying
in the trump era the u.s had a very bad
relationship with china
and people are going to ask well oh that
makes sense because china was a
totalitarian state that was putting a
million people in concentration camps
and doing medical experimentation and
testing vaccines on people
obviously you'd have a bad relationship
with china and the answer is
well no actually that really wasn't the
issue at all actually we just had a
problem with
you know they were selling soybeans kind
of cheap and i don't want to understand
the importance of that
right yeah but now now of course it's
more than uh it's more
yes and of course it's more complicated
than just even even the soybean
explanation but you're right that when
we look back at it
it may be misremembered but listen this
is one of the rel
the the additional reasons why having
actual
diplomats or people who defer to
diplomats
still matters in 2020
and having people who prioritize human
rights i mean didn't care
i mean and i would i would point just in
one second the the biden campaign put
out a very good statement the other day
there the trump administration is
apparently considering
labeling this a genocide um which i
think would be an enormous step
um hopefully they do that um the biden
campaign put out a good statement saying
i believe saying we will do that if we
come into office
but i think that's something that we
should be putting a lot of pressure uh
on institutions to do right now is to
really make some kind of impact on that
issue
all right not a not an unreasonable idea
i appreciate the phone call
thank you david all right take care